大家好,我是老猫
欢迎来到老贸易指标
这是一个致力于测试各种股市指标和策略的频道
在我的每一个视频中
所有策略将会被手动测试100次
大家好
老猫今天讲一个连机构都比较喜欢用的指标
OBV
能量潮指标
英文是unbalanced volume
在股市技术分析中
主要有四大要素
量价时空
OVV就是用这个量作为一个突破口
将成交量与股价的关系
直接数字化和直观化
老猫十几年前
刚入股市的时候
作为曾经的新手
向来只看价格
从不看量
因为那个时候老猫根本不知道量的重要性
所以有一句老话就是
新手看价,老手看量
所以那个时候老猫自然也吃了不少的教训
现在老猫把量作为第一个在开仓之前
必须要研究的要素
因为量在价先
就好比我们中国古代打仗
兵马未动,粮草先行
这个量就是股市里的粮草
在开始看这个指标计算公司之前
我们先来看一下
这个OBV能量潮的理论基础是什么
第一
投资者对价格与价值的分歧越大
成交量越大
反之成交量就小
换句话说
多空看法一致的时候
成交量就会很小
这个时候
如果多头占优势
那多头就会继续这个趋势
所以很多慢牛的行情
是最好的多头行情
价格变化不大
成交量也不大
但是往往可以走上非常长的时间
第二,重力原理
上升的物体直早会下跌
而物体上升所需要的能量
比下跌的时候多很多
换句话说
如果涨到高点的股价迟早会下跌
那股价上升时所需的能量远比下落的时候要大
所以股价上升
特别是上升初期的时候
必须有较大的成交量配合
反过来股价下跌的时候
则不必消费很大的能量
因此下跌的时候成交量不一定要放大
甚至有萎缩都没关系
但是如果下跌的时候成交量也放大
那下跌的幅度跟速度一定会非常快
第三,惯性原理
一旦某个股市品种被炒热
那热点就会持续一段时间
对应的成交量和价格
也会在期间内产生较大的波动
反之,如果成交量和价格波动不断萎缩
市场开始冷却
那那一只股票品种就会无人问津
在之后的一段时间里会一直冷却
直到下一次再次被人关注
相信以上三点理论依据不太难理解
接下来老样子,我们来看一下计算公式
如果收盘价比前日收盘价高
OBV就等于前日的OBV
再加上当日的成交量
如果收盘价比前日收盘价低
那OBV就等于前日的OBV
减去当天的成交量
如果收盘价与前日收盘价一样
那就是维持不动
所以这个计算公式非常简单
就是单纯的计算成交量的变动
好了
接下来我们到图表中去看一下
我们来到TradingView
首先把这个OBV添加一下
我们这里使用的是黄金
一小时级别
添加了这个OVV之后
可以看到就是这样一根单一的曲线
看一下参数设置
这里实际上是没有任何参数设置的
添加完了之后就是
直接是这样一根线
可以看到这个OVV这根线的走势
跟上面这个K线的走势相类似
如果是有个峰值
这边也会有一个尖的峰值出现
如果有往下一个低谷
这里会有一个明显的低谷
然后这样往上
那这个OVV常用的一些方式
当然是来看这些量价上的关系
如果要一波上升的行情
这个OVV上升
肯定是代表了这个量
成交量的在上升
如果这个OVV上升的同时
价格也在不断上升
那说明这是一个
非常健康的上升的走势
但是如果
比如说你看到这里
价格回调了一下
然后继续上升
继续上升的这个时候
你就会发现
这边的高点
已经比这边的高点
这边高了很多
对不对
所以就形成了一个背离
这个价格还在往上
这个OVV的值已经在往下了
说明这一是一波行情的终结
所以在这边的时候
价格就会往下跑了
那这个其实是一个背离的形态
老猫使用这个OVV的时候
更倾向于使用大级别的
因为知道这个不同的时间段
不管是欧盘还是亚盘还是美盘
实际上成交量是非常不一样的
所以如果要使用成交量这个概念的时候
老猫经常会用比较大级别的这个周期
比如说12小时或者一天
这样相对来说比较准确
不然比如说在亚盘的时候
有可能某些时间点成交量非常大
因为开盘
在有些时候成交量又非常低
因为盘还没有开
所以用大级别的周期来判断量的话
是比较相对准确的
然后还有一种OVV的用法就是
再看一个吸筹过程
如果你是用威科夫交易法
或者是量价供需关系的
这样的交易系统的时候
你一定会关注这个量
比如说这里一个区域
是一个往下走的
这样一个锯齿形的
这样一个形态
但是在OVV这边可以看到它基本是平的虽然价格的底部跟顶部在不断地往下走
这是往下走的
但是这个OVV基本上没有太动
所以这个时候就要关注了
因为这是一种背离的形态
所以这个时候要关注什么呢
就是在当有这个OVV这个值
突然之间往上升的时候
就代表这是一波行情要准备开始叙利往上走了
因为之前讲过OVV的理论基础是
如果在上升的初期
这个成交量就必须得要放量
需要有量的支持来提升价格
所以在初期一定要放量
所以在这边的时候你可以看到
突然之间有一个放量
当然在这个图上的形态也是一个突破
这边有一个顶部的突破
所以在这边放量的时候
就可以开始准备左手去做多了
如果我们单独使用OVV
实际上我们在这里是没有办法来进行一个开仓点位的确认的
所以这个OVV的指标大多的时候只能作为一个辅助的指标
帮助我们主要的策略增加成功率
因为它单独来使用
比如说在这边操作的时候
可能你只能按照这个K线的形态
突破的时候做多
然后根据这个OVV
看这个量有没有跟上去
跟上去了做一个确认
这时候你这个多单
就可以放心地持有
好
这个就是一个
OVV的这样一个用法
然后今天要讲到这个策略呢
是使用这个OVV的背驴的策略
因为之前提到过
如果这个价格
这边的价格跟这边的价格差不多
这边的价格呢
更低,结果它高位更高
所以比它也高
比这里也高
所以这边就是个背离
所以我们需要在接下来的这个行情中开始找点位进行做空。
那今天要讲到这个策略实际上很简单,
我们老样子要添加一个均线。
这里老猫用到的是21天的均线,
当然你也可以用20的均线。
经常看老猫节目的人知道
老猫更多的倾向于使用
斐波那切数列
这个21就是斐波那切数列
然后为了看清楚
这个齿轮的这个背离的情况
老猫又简单的把这个
OVV的这个指标进行
EMA的这个处理
如果你用Tradimu的话
可以问老猫所取这个代码
实际上也非常简单
基本上就是算出了这个OEV以后
然后再做一个EMA的平均
得到一个平均值
跟平均值去比较
低于平均值的
它就会显示这个下面绿的
高于平均值的就会变成红的
就等于说OVV在普通这个图表上看
实际上是没有这个0的分界线的
因为成交量嘛
最底部就是0
最上面是没有界线的
但是老猫就做了一个边界
如果低于一个平均值的话
那就会显示出绿色
然后高于平均值的话就会有红色
然后因为通过平均值的计算
我可以把这个
各种锯齿形状
可以画得更清晰一点
这样方便老猫在回车的时候
来看这个背离的情况
好了我可以把这个
原来这个默认的OBB给关掉
得到一个这样的OBB
那这个策略呢实际上也非常简单
拿一条2C的均线
基本上就是用均线的金死差的方式
这个不同于我们以往金死差这个操作
我们这边需要的条件有两个
第一个就是OBB产生背离
比如说这里
这是一个触发的条件之一
但是触发了这个条件之后呢
暂时先不开仓
等到什么时候开仓呢
等到这个价格穿过了这条21天的均线的时候
形成了一个死差
然后我们就在
这个死叉
形成之后的第二根K线
开尺的地方
做空
因为这边是死叉
顶部背离
顶部背离加死叉
然后我们把这个值
设置在
这个前高的地方
因为我们觉得这个就是一个顶部了
所以它不可能比这个顶部再高
如果它比这个顶部再高的话
就说明这不是顶部
那这个策略就失败了
然后自己调整好盈亏比
一贯使用1比1.5这样的一个策略
那所以看到这边就可能达不到这个1比1.5
那正常的时候
怎么样来平仓呢
如果不是按照一个固定的盈亏比
怎么来平仓呢
平仓的方式实际上也是一样的
因为我们开仓的这个思路
是它有一个顶部背离
如果它出现一个底部背离
那我们是不是应该也要平仓了呢
那这边来看一下
这个底部的背离不是太明显
大概都是向上的
这里到这里
也是一样的方向
但是除了背离的状态
因为我们还有第二个条件
就是它这个均线开始形成一个金叉
所以这就破掉了我们第二个条件
所以任何的时候
只要其中一个条件被破坏了
那我们就要选择平仓
开仓的时候是有两个条件
一个条件就是顶部的背离
顶部的背离
第二个条件就是形成死叉
那反过来
如果其中任何一条被打破的话我们就应该选择平仓比如说在这里实际上这边已经形成了一个新的经差
那我们就要选择来进行平仓的处理
因为我们开仓是通过这两个条件来开仓的
如果没有按照我们预期的方向走
然后打破了我们开仓的条件
那我们就要选择手动来止损
当然老猫依旧是使用固定的1比1.5的这样的策略
来测试这个OVV
能够帮助我们这个均线金矢差的策略
能够提高多少的胜率
我们再来看一下
这个盘面上还有没有更多的
这边就有
首先
这个价格再往下走
但是这边底部
已经形成了背离
所以这个时候我们就选择观望
等待它形成一个金叉的时候
然后我们开始做多
如果要设置1比1.5
这个盈亏比的话
实际上
非常容易就会达到了
因为你这个底部就要选择前低
然后这样一波上去
如果是选择手动来指引的话
实际上这一波还是可以吃蛮大一波的
往上往上
直到这边的时候
实际上已经开始有一点背离了
但是你就可以选择移动止盈
至于这个
盈亏比跟止云
这边老猫就不再多赘述了
因为我们使用的是1比1.5
比较机械化的这样一个操作
那如果你能手动来看盘
实时地观测这个盘面的话
那肯定是根据这个盘面
如果它这个背离非常厉害
然后它更多的像要穿过这条均线的时候
那你就可以选择平仓了
好了就是这样一个
OVV背离外加奥西天均线
金死差的这样一个策略
接下来老猫会来测试100次
看其胜率有多少
为了保证策略的一致性
我们依旧使用1比1.5这个盈亏比
以及1%的风险控制
为了方便统计
我这里用Excel表格来记录每一次交易
0代表亏损
1代表盈利
通过Excel的公式和图表功能
最后我们可以看到最终的盈率
以及资金的变化局限
为了减少视频的时间
我已经把速度调成8倍数
如果你想查看每一笔开仓的点位
以及止损的设置
可以把视频速度调慢
或者按暂停
字幕志愿者 杨茜茜
字幕志愿者 李宗盛
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive
经过100字的回测
我们可以看到胜率是58%
盈利率是45%
应该算是挺不错的策略了
我们再来看一下资金曲线图
这里之前老猫提过
如果资金曲线图是成锯齿形不断上升
没有连续长时间的亏损或者盈利
资金图上没有连续向上或者连续向下的极端的走势
像这样的崎岖的向上的走势
是一种比较稳定的走势
应该来说可以不断地稳定的盈利
最后总结
因为这个策略用到了均线的策略
以及能量的策略
所以在外汇品种中可能会要谨慎地使用
因为外汇里边所看到的量
是这个K线图绘制出来的量
而非真实的量
然后在震荡行情中
由于均线的滞后性
所以如果一旦是震荡行情
这个策略有可能会连续被止损
最后老猫觉得
这个策略应该是相当不错的策略
因为用法非常简单
只要满足两个条件
开仓的点位和平仓的点位也非常明显
如果长时间持续按照这个策略不断执行的话
老猫觉得应该会有一个比较稳定的收入
最后在视频结束之前
老猫从网友的问题中选择三个来回答一下
第一个
老猫你为什么不用EA来回测
这是一个很好的问题
很多年前老猫也是写了一大堆各种各样的EA
用MT4、MT5
但是最近很长时间老猫都实在使用TradingView
并不是MT4和MT5不好用
而是TradingView实在是太好用了
而且上面的Pinescript
基本上不需要太多的学习
你就可以写出各种各样不同的指标和策略
而且Tradiview也提供了那种一键
可以测试策略胜率的这种功能
老猫平时也有会在用
但是这都不是主要原因
最主要的原因是老猫喜欢人为的去看盘
当然很多的策略
用EA用脚本去跑的话非常有效率
但是往往在实测用手动去操作的时候
就会发现好像跟测试的结果有比较大的出入
所以手动回测历史数据
可以让老猫对于K线的形态
以及走势会有更深刻的理解
进而增加自己的盘感
所以这也算是一种锻炼和修行吧
第二个问题
老猫,你讲了这么多不同的策略
那你自己是用什么策略
这也是一个很有意思的问题
其实老猫想说
各种策略我都用
但是并不是混用
比如说我做外汇
做日元兑美元
我可能只用一个策略
然后持续地用这一种策略
因为经过我的回测
我知道它的胜率就是有这么多
可能一单两单损了
但是接下来我一定会盈利
所以这就是一个数学概率问题
如果我对于这一个品种
持续地使用同一种策略
如果它的资金曲线图
跟我预想的走势没有太大的出入的话
我会不断地一直用它
直到有一天
它的资金走势图不再像我想象的一样
那我可能想要尝试着去换一个其他的策略
然后进行一轮自己的回测
看这个策略符不符合这个数据
能不能达到我的盈亏比
以及风险控制的要求
所以老猫并不只局限于用一种策略
各种不同的策略
包括RSI的背离
MFI的背离
布林黛
以及金死X
MACD
Ichimoku
各种各样的策略
老猫都会用
只不过是它不会全部用在一个品种上
在一个品种上
老猫只会持续不断地用一种策略
所以如果你觉得有一个策略
理解起来非常简单
操作起来不麻烦
各种条理跟逻辑都比较清晰
那你不妨就去回测一下
你想要做的那个品种
看它通过历史数据的回测
能不能达到一个比较好的盈亏比
以及胜率
然后再来决定说
要用这个策略要用多久
什么时候就是一个放弃这个策略的点
这些都是在使用策略之前
你必须要先想好的一个问题
等于说你在使用这些策略的时候
就加上了各种的条件跟限制
如果满足不了这些条件
那你就得要重新考虑换一个策略
然后新手经常会遇到的一个误区就是
比如说我用一个策略去开仓
用另外一个策略去平仓
然后今天用这个策略
明天用另外一个策略
或者觉得用一个策略
我可以用所有的品种
这样实际上是非常不对的
因为世界上没有一个完美的策略
圣杯是不存在的
最后一个问题
老猫
你讲了这么多不同的指标
我们到哪里去可以下载这些指标
首先老猫觉得
老猫并没有更改这些指标的本质
老猫做的这些自定义的指标的修改
只是局限于视觉上的效果
为了让看图更方便一点
所以如果你不用TradingView
你用系统自带的或者平台自带的指标
应该也是完全没有问题的
因为策略的原理就在那里
但是如果你也用TradingView
也想用老猫自定义的这些指标
你可以在视频的下方留言
或者给我发消息
如果你也是用Google的账号的话
我可以通过Google的文档分享给你
好了
这一期我们就到这里
最后
大家觉得本视频有帮助的话
记得按赞和评论
还没关注和订阅的朋友
记得关注和订阅哦
我是老猫
谢谢大家观看
我们下期再见